come on purple
hey beauty hey michelle how
are you you look great thank you honey
you giving braid and shoulder all
of it i broke out
[Laughter]
you gotta dress up or something listen
i can i can only imagine though angela
that it does feel
good a little because i've lived in
sweats for the last i can't tell you how
long
i i can imagine it does feel good to put
on a lip and a lash and get
real cute just for everything yes
well wait a minute i do need i do want
to know who did this
thank you dolce cabana heavens and beads
and beating and sequins
[Laughter]
i just got it all yes baby do it for
tonight because who knows what
tomorrow's gonna bring
it's so i'm still trying to wrap my head
around all this new normal and what
we're doing i guess we're just making it
happen are you gonna
watch the show there tonight are you
just kind of in and out presenting out
and what are you gonna do i'm in and out
yeah amen they got us all you know
segregated to ourselves
and sort of like a a two photograph
uh step and repeat
so so civilized you know so yeah in and
out and then it'll spray it all down for
the next
presenters to come in behind yourself
well is there like a post plan because
this can't go to waste i mean courtney's
got to like
do something with you in this in this
outfit
no actually he left for chicago uh
day before yesterday he's there doing a
new a new television
uh series on 6th street so he's
he actually flew to chicago for a couple
weeks two weeks
um with quarantine mm-hmm
so i told him if you want to see it he's
got to tune in to uh mp3 like everybody
else
yeah i love it now did you have to with
you know you're putting your look
together
this year did you do like let me do a
matching face mask i have to wear a
shield like did you think about those
things too
no i didn't actually i had the regular
light blue baby blue
paper mask because we had to have one
when we got out of the car when we were
and actually i was walking to you know
go do an interview and i said oh
this is really clashing aren't i with my
with my dress i didn't think if i was
just like okay just
give it to me but no so because i didn't
mess up my makeup either so the light
face is good but come on that's a canvas
that anybody can work with so whatever
whatever um what are you looking forward
to most on the show tonight with it i
know being by coastal we
really don't know what it's gonna look
like
we're gonna see how that goes and
hopefully it'll go off without a hitch
you know yeah everybody's had lots and
lots of time to
plan and coordinate i guess but uh it'll
be
interesting i know my you know my heart
my son chadwick is up for an award so
look forward to you know to um to just
see
his face on the screen pop up on the
screen there who knows what'll happen
but uh it's nice to to remember and
recall his brilliance and his spirit
so looking forward to that and really
just to celebrate
all of my all of my colleagues and to do
so safely
you know it does break our heart to have
to honor him posthumously and to speak
to
about him in the past tense but you know
you know his work you work with him like
you said he is your film
son to see him honored and lifted up in
this way how does that make you it it's
it's a sweet spirit it's a sweet feeling
in my heart
you know um we we miss him terribly but
uh
he was kind of individual in the kind of
work he did
you know is is worthy of remembrance so
that we are doing the uh the most
beautiful and righteous thing
in doing so well speaking of your
husband courtney
who you said is in chicago we're going
to be with him on tuesday for aretha
um yeah and so what what did you think
when he's cast to play aretha's
dad i know you guys sat with her at her
table at the kennedy center honor so
you know what are you thinking about
about this oh
he was excited i was excited and just
perfect you know
he fancies himself a little jack-o-lant
preacher
he's played he's played a couple of them
he
is but of course with his dramatic flair
so
he he's a a scene cheering stealer
so i'm looking forward i'm really
looking forward to that you know and
it'll be here soon
i think mid-march is coming really yeah
so i'm i'm
really excited about it and about his
performance uh we're all ready for it
okay um
i just gotta ask you real quick before i
let you go is it true
that your children have never seen
in my opinion your greatest performance
like one of the greatest performances on
film ever
you tina turner love got to do with it
your kids have never seen it absolutely
true they have never
seen it no you know courtney is the one
to go on you know to go on and see what
the ratings
are for movies so he didn't have to do
that for
for what's love but they watched i think
animated movies
animated movies a couple of years ago
um but no they've never seen it and i
think they're mature enough now to check
it out
but you know they're teenagers and
they're into their own thing
you know they're into their own thing
and moms are just
not that cool now other folks aren't
moms are
if i can get their friends if their
friends have seen it
that will pique their interest that
might beat their interests
send them over to auntie shell's house
and we'll have a movie night
and they will see it before they come
back home angela i'm serious like it
those those babies have traumatized i
don't know
no those babies have got it's literally
i mean i can't even
people ask me what the the the person
who is
deserved the oscar the most who hadn't
gotten it it's you for me
every single time like oh thank you
darling
ladies make them watch that like it's
you you were just transformative in it
so i can't believe they haven't seen it
it's coming new respect is coming
what's going on with athena and the rest
of the cast for the rest of the sea you
got the
you've got the finale coming up right
not yet
i i know they're talking about the
finale but we still
we're about we still have about five
five or six more episodes to shoot
before the finale
unless it's splitting it up because of
the pandemic so you get like a four
episode
arc well i think there's like i think i
heard that there was a winter finale
coming but maybe not maybe i heard wrong
that they maybe they were gonna try to
make it last longer
but um maybe not well you probably heard
right
i'm the one who's not in the know
because i
am in my nose is in the script trying to
learn
like three and four scripts
simultaneously so i just know you're
right you've got it straight
well what is going on with athena and
the and the rest of the
uh the gang well you know some old
you know one of the things i i love
about this show is that
we can reach back and and bring bring
other characters back other storylines
and that's a big one uh something that
happened you know with
with may you know her old nemesis
has uh yes has come back around
we're gonna see what happened mom is not
too very pleased with that
whatsoever you know i love they put you
know
professional police woman down and pick
up you know black mama
i love it she ain't never too far away
black mom was never too far away
thank you so much angela you look
beautiful and i'm so glad to talk to you
just see your face
in this whole craziness thank you thank
you for having me i love you
all right darla love you too see y'all
later
[Music]